Why can we access array properties?
What's so special about arrays?
>> Arrays are actually special kinds of objects in JavaScript.
In fact, this is a nice transition.
Let's get into objects.
>> Dude, dude, oh, dude.
My hands are like handy.
>> Yes they are.
And while you're staring at your hands, I'm going to be a professional.
>> Okay.
What I mean is hands are like objects because,
they can hold information and do things.
>> True.
That is an analogy.
>> Objects in JavaScript can be declared and defined in a few different ways.
And all of them are different than the way Python defines classes and
objects, because there are no classes in JavaScript.
>> Let's repeat that.
JavaScript doesn't include classes, just objects.
There are ways to mimic classes in some respects, but
they're still just objects.
>> Right.
And this has some pretty interesting implications.
Check out the instructor notes for more information.
Let's start defining objects with object literal notation.
In object literal notation, we'll use the same var syntax as we had before.
Then we'll give the object a name, then an equal sign.
And then the object is going to be defined within these curly braces.
These curly braces indicate that you're using object literal notation.
>> Let's define an object for my biography.
Then inside the curly braces,
we can define the object's properties using key value pairs.
I'll create a property called name and save my name as the value.
I'll do the same for age, this time using the number 32, my age.
>> Notice that we surrounded the properties with quotation marks,
because they're strings and there's a comma between the two key value pairs.
>> thanks.
But we can say whatever we want here.
We could even save an array in our object.
For instance, I want to add skills to my biography.
So let's take Cameron's skills from up here and
add it to my biography down here.
>> Is that because you're jealous?
>> Eh, maybe.
>> This is pretty straightforward.
To access these properties later, just as we did with the array length,
we simply add .property after the object name.
So if I wanted to appended James' name to the page, all I'd need to
do is access the bio.name property to pull James' name out of his bio object.
Then, I'll go ahead and append it to the page, come over here, hit refresh.
We can see that we've got James on our page now.
>> Nice.
Let's give our students a shot.